hey everyone so this is this is a  stand-up bit I have and I'm making it  into a little video for you here I was  thinking about ever since I started  dating guys back in high school even  though my parents didn't want me to I  did anyway and I experienced love  troubles boy problems I would always  listen to Gwen Stefani to help me feel  strong she's always been cool she's  always had confidence and self-respect  stuff that I never had and even to this  day if I if I'm experienced experiencing  boy troubles and blessing no doubt in my  car all the time except when I do it's  dangerous because I'm making Gwen  Stefani's face while driving for long  time I was loved  not only love I was obsessed no one else  could touch it didn't work out uncover  the shells  it was the simple things a simple kind  of light  I better go to a therapist